[موسيقى]
Snakes on a Plane لقد
كان مجرد فيلم ولكن الثعابين في
الجدران مثل الكابوس،
تمكنت أمبر هول، الأم العازبة من Big Time،
أخيرًا من شراء منزلها الأول في إحدى
ضواحي دنفر، ولكن حتى عندما
أفرغت أمتعتها اكتشفت أن آخرين قد قاموا بذلك  تم
نقلهم بالفعل وهم
يخرجون حرفيًا من الأعمال الخشبية من كل
فتحة في الشق، عثر أحد كلابها على
أول كلب في المرآب، حسنًا يا رفاق،
هنا هو الثعبان منذ ذلك الحين،
رأت أمبر ما يصل إلى 30 راعي الثعبان الذي
استأجرته تعتقد  هناك وكر من
الثعابين مما قد يعني مئات
الأطفال بالنسبة لـ Amber، إنه أمر مرعب ولكنني
الآن أيضًا عقلي يلعب الحيل
عليّ في كل مرة أعتقد أنني أرى الثعابين
في كل مكان أذهب إليه في ذلك اليوم،
اعتقدت للحظة أنها أحضرت
واحدة بطريقة ما  من المنزل إلى وظيفتها
كمشرفة تمريض، لكنه لم يكن سوى شاحن
هاتف مخطط ملفوف حول كرسي، إذا
سألتها عن حلمها في
امتلاك منزل أخيرًا، ستجعلني أبكي، لقد
أنفقت كل قرش كان لدي للحصول على هذا
المنزل الآن يقول الناس إنها يجب أن
تنتقل ولكن الأمر يشبه المكان الذي من المفترض أن
أذهب إليه، قام ابن عمي بإعداد صفحة GoFundMe
نطلق عليها اسم Snakes على صفحة للمساعدة في دفع تكاليف
إزالة الثعبان وإعادة البناء
وربما محامٍ ولكن Amber لم
تفقدها  روح الدعابة التي تخيفني
عندما جاء شقيقها وصديقها
لتركيب الرفوف، وضعت أطفالها على شكل
ثعبان مطاطي في خزانة، وأوقفت أحد
الرجال في أثره، واستمر أطفالها الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 11
و 13 عامًا في محاولة تخويفهم، حيث وضعوها بشكل
استراتيجي جميعًا  فوق المنزل على
حد تعبير إنديانا جونز، لماذا يجب
أن تكون ثعابين، صحيح أن هذه
ثعابين غير ضارة وليست
ثعابين ولكن لا تزال آمبر تسرق
الضغط، وأنا بالتأكيد أقوم
بفحص كامل للمرحاض في كل مرة
أجلس فيها.
يمين